[Music]
this pencil eraser sized mass of cells
is something called a brain organoid
it's a collection of lab-grown neurons
and other brain tissue that scientists
can use to learn about full-grown human
brains and it can be grown from a sample
of your skin cells why would we need
such a thing neuro scientists face a
challenge shielded by our thick skulls
and swaddled in layers of protective
tissue the human brain is extremely
difficult to observe in action for
centuries scientists have tried to
understand them using autopsies animal
models and in recent years imaging
techniques we've learned a lot through
all these methods but they have
limitations conditions like Alzheimer's
and schizophrenia and the effect on the
human brain of diseases like Zika
continue to hide beyond our view and our
understanding Enterbrain organoids which
function like human brains but aren't
part of an organism each one comes from
an undifferentiated stem cell which is a
cell that can develop into any tissue in
the body from bone to brain scientists
can make undifferentiated stem cells
from skin cells that means they can take
a skin sample from a person with a
particular condition and generate brain
organoids from that person the hardest
part of growing a brain organoid which
stumped scientists for years was finding
the perfect combination of sugars
proteins vitamins and minerals that
would induce the stem cell to develop a
neural identity that was only discovered
recently in 2013 the rest of the process
is surprisingly easy a neural stem cell
essentially grows itself similar to how
a seed grows into a plant all it needs
are the brains equivalents of soil water
and sunlight a special gel to simulate
embryonic tissue a warm incubator set at
body temperature and a bit of motion to
mimic blood flow the stem cell grows
into a very small version of an early
developing human brain complete with
neurons that can connect to one another
and make simplified neural networks as
mini brains grow they follow all the
steps of fetal brain development by
observing this process we can learn how
our neurons develop as well as how we
end up with so many more of them in our
cortex the part responsible for higher
cognition like logic and reasoning than
other species being able to grow brains
in the lab even tiny ones raises ethical
questions like can they think for
themselves or develop consciousness and
the answer is no for several reasons a
brain organoid has the same tissue types
as a full sized brain but isn't
organized the same way the organoid is
similar to an airplane that's been taken
apart and reassembled at random you
could still study the wings the engine
and other parts but the plane could
never fly similarly a brain organoid
allows us to study different types of
brain tissue but can't think and even if
many brains were organized like a real
brain they still wouldn't be able to
reason or develop consciousness a big
part of what makes our brains so smart
is their size and mini brains have only
about 100,000 neurons compared to the 86
billion in a full-sized brain scientists
aren't likely to grow larger brain
organoids any time soon
without blood vessels to feed them their
size is limited to one centimeter at
most
finally mini brains aren't able to
interact with the outside world we learn
by interacting with our environments
receiving inputs through our eyes ears
and other sensory organs and reacting in
turn
the complex neural networks that
underlie conscious thoughts and actions
developed from this feedback loop
without it the organoids can never form
a functional network there's nothing
quite like the actual human brain but
mini brains are an unprecedented tool
for studying everything from development
to disease with luck these humble
organoids can help us discover what
makes the human brain unique and maybe
bring us closer to answering the age-old
question what makes us human ted-ed is a
non-profit if you value our work please
consider supporting it on patreon.com
slash ted-ed
[Music]